Північне Причорномор'я є невід'ємною
частиною середземноморської культури.
І коли вже 27 років говорять про національну ідею,
і ми йдемо в Європу,
я не розумію, чому так рідко
говорять про те, що Європа і демократична культура
були на наших теренах ще 500 р. до н. е.
Така була авантюра...
Ще 1989-го року це розпочалося. В Одесі збудували...
Вірніше за ініціативою одеситів була збудована дієра —
античне парусне судно, копія давньогрецького корабля.
Я дійшов тільки до острова Ельба і там зупинився,
бо мені в Італії подобалося, я там знайшов свій інтерес.
І саме чому я кажу про цю подорож — там я побачив,
як живуть середземноморські люди,
живуть вільно, на великих просторах,
не так, як в наші радянські часи були квартирки.
І я почав будувати таку хатинку середземноморську, свою.
Це Геродот — саме та вулиця,
яку я перейменував років шість тому.
Сільрада все затвердила —
офіційно це вулиця Геродота.
Геродот був в Ольвії, я не скажу точно дату,
близько ІV ст. до н. е.,
і залишив найбільш цікаві спостереження
про Ольвію, про скіфів.
Ось це справжній античний камінь.
Це один з перших великих камінців,
які я знайшов в селі.
Але це явно ольвійський камінь,
бо і форми, і оброблений він...
Я робив проєкти протягом 20 років,
саме на території Ольвії,
бо я займаюся вже 20 років ленд-артом,
а може більше ніж 20 років.
Ленд-арт передбачає великий простір,
а там 36 гектарів,
якраз для мене достатньо для творчості.
Тетяна також художниця,
вона співпрацює у всіх моїх проєктах.
Проєкти останній час здебільшого
пов'язані з фотографуванням.
У нас дві великі теми — це нічні зйомки,
ми робимо реконструкції вогнем, малюємо архітектуру.
Ну... Таня працює у мене фотографом.
Ні! Він бігає спортивно, а я стою спокійнененько.
Це процес такий...
Візуально не дуже зрозумілий,
якщо дивитися збоку, але на фото це дуже ефектно,
бо виходять такі реконструкції
без всяких конструкцій дерев'яних чи металевих.
Я за одну хвилину
можу намалювати великий храм,
чого не можуть зробити
архітектори і реставратори ніколи. Чи реконструктори.
Він мене врятував двічі, двічі життя врятував.
І як чесна людина повинен був одружитися.
Молодість була в спелеології і піших походах.
Так і познайомились... Не за мольбертом!
Була така печера, де ходи були вузькі,
і вони були з водою.
І треба було йти —
ногами розпиратися і руками.
І я туди упала, і Володя мене витягнув.
Родився я в Луганській області.
Зараз це територія якраз така,
що називається погранична.
Часто ви мабуть чули —  Золоте.
Я в дитинстві виїхав.
В 17 років як поїхав в Одесу,
так я, можна сказати, додому не повертався.
Та територія також має свої культурні шари,
і для мене одна з основних причин,
чому я оселився тут,
в Ольвії дуже потужний культурний шар.
Там культурний шар досягає восьми метрів.
Такий еталонний пам'ятник,
як Ольвія, в світі важко знайти.
Бо тут все залишалося, консервувалося кожні сто років.
Все залишилося непотурбованим.
Був період — я займався українською темою,
але коли все серед художників почало
скидатися на змагання, хто більше український,
я трохи від цього відійшов і зробив свій вибір як художник
Північного Причорномор'я або Півдня України.
Найбільше досягнення в Ольвії за всі роки
мабуть тільки те, що її почали охороняти.
Коли приїхали, ми ризикували бути битими,
але якось пройшли ті суворі часи,
коли тут селяни зустрічали чужих агресивно.
Воно якось залишилося в минулому поколінні.
А так ми досить швидко привчили людей
до нашої присутності в селі.
Вони навіть пишаються тим, що ми часто
на телебаченні виступаємо.
Я зазвичай не кажу нічого поганого про селян.
Кажу, що в нас народ продвинутий,
бо ці підлітки, які шукають скарби, ідуть по вулиці,
і я зі спини чую:
«То ж були іонійські амфори!»
І я так думаю: ну в якому селі можуть
такі проблемні підлітки розмовляти про археологічні тонкощі?
Все Причорномор'я — практично це була частина Європи.
Зараз лунає Львів, Західна Україна,
були частиною Австроугорщини, Польщі і так далі,
і тому ми близькі до Європи...
Я стверджую, що ми були ближче дві з половиною
тисячі років тому до Європи, ніж сьогодні.
Я завжди казав, що Північне Причорномор'я —
це особливий регіон.
Зараз це не в тренді.
Це якби тема для відокремленнь...
Але насправді єдність в тому,
що вони різні, а не в тому, що вони однакові.
Якщо різні люди можуть об'єднатися,
то важливіше ніж однакові.
Я думаю, що українські регіони повинні виходити з цього,
і не нівелювати різницю,
а навпаки підкреслювати і пропагувати.
От я пропагую південну ментальність!